[Music]
Architects with hand in hand building
different movers as we say but they were
playing off the idea about what does it
mean for China to be a new modern
society
hello and welcome to Chinese Whispers
with me Cindy you every episode I'll be
talking to journalists experts and
longtime China Watchers about the latest
in Chinese politics society and more
there'll be a smattering of History to
catch you up on the background knowledge
and some context as well how did the
Chinese see these issues
in the last four decades hundreds of
millions of Chinese have moved into
cities today two-thirds of the country
live in cities compared to just one
third in 1985 and many of these are
Urban centers with tens of millions of
people mega cities that many in the west
have never even heard of
on this episode I'd like to take a look
at urban life in China so news to so
much of the population I'm joined by
Austin Williams who is an architect
turned journalist and author of two
books on Chinese architecture so Austin
to start with I'd like to paint a
picture for listeners of what life is
like in these urban areas
um it's also partly because that's what
I know best because I was born in
Nanjing which is a city of 9 million
people with tier 2 City in the Chinese
Communist tiering system so can we start
by looking at how they live so the
accommodation the residential compounds
the charge of Chinese cities
um I think they'll be quite alien to
Brits who are used to living maybe in
semi-detached houses or terrorist
housing or cold attacks that kind of
stuff so can you explain what what is a
Celsius what is a residential compound
uh well it's um just just to say I think
it's similar in some respects to World
communities in the UK but different yeah
so they're not necessarily Posh and
affluent they're normally kind of Fairly
bog standard and even even house migrant
workers but effectively they are World
encampments which basically in the old
days used to be kind of maybe single
two-story houses but now are high rise
so you can maybe get I don't know maybe
a 100 tower blocks 15 stories high uh
but within a walled area with two
gateways uh manned by a security guard
that everybody ignores uh that you can
just that you can walk into it it
contains then you know Landscaping maybe
up to 50 Landscaping it's actually kind
of quite nice little areas
um and they have a little sharp and
they'll have Community play areas for
children and these blocks and you'll
you'll go to your number 65b block and
and lock yourself away so they are kind
of contained areas and you've seen it I
mean maybe people have seen it on the
kovid
footage you know where the enclosure is
not so much the the building but the but
the actual walled area under kovid under
the strength of kovid in the early days
especially in Shanghai they were locking
you into your actual apartment yes you
were actually taping up the door locking
it shut you weren't allowed to come out
and it was monitored so she did actually
come out for too long then they'd send
the boys around but in general you're
now still allowed to maybe Waltz around
in the gardens as long as you're kind of
keeping in your social distancing and
keeping your face mask on but you can't
go beyond that's where that's where the
barriers were set up and they're private
companies private Ward compounds so it's
not you know as if um the government is
making everyone live in these places you
buy a flat according to your house
Builder that you want to live in their
compound you want to live with their
Aesthetics and their landscaping and all
this yeah but they've pushed it so they
so about five years ago they were
pushing to get rid of these compounds
because it's kind of uh blocking you
know so the grid system within China is
again alien to the UK so rather than
kind of a nice vernacular bouncy shapy
kind of curved roads you have these very
straight narrow Avenues and streets
um and within those blocks very large
blocks you have single compounds
um and obviously that then doesn't help
traffic flow it doesn't help kind of
people being able to take shortcuts
because you can't do it so basically the
government is basically saying we should
do away with compounds this is what I
said five years ago now that hasn't
really come to fruition because of too
many of them and it's too difficult to
do second thing to say is that within
those compounds you still have you know
the old Communist Party member the old
Communist party setup so there's always
a representative in there who is making
sure that the community when they form
their Community groups whether it's
around ping pong tables or knitting or
Tai Chi or whatever it might be those
Community groups don't get too above
themselves that they still have to
relate to the Communist Party official
who will stand there and tell them you
know what is appropriate and report back
if too many people are organ
independently so you know it's still
it's still China no no of course and
that and that's the kind of neighborhood
committee that we hear so much about
during the lockdowns isn't it they're
not quite party members they might be
but they're not necessarily and then
obviously not police people either yeah
well lots of people ignore them you know
what I mean and I think that there's a
lot of I mean they're like the
neighborhood Busy Bodies almost I mean
you only some people would go on the
neighborhood watch I think yeah but it's
like the security guards I was saying
the wardens at the entrance to the
compound you know there's a very
interesting thing about China which is
that you know you imagine it's a well it
is a one-party State it's kind of very
officious but then when Ordinary People
come across ordinary Waters and they
tell you to stop people ignore them you
know when you go onto a tube station and
they say put your bags through a
scanning machine they just ignore them
and walk straight through so there's a
contempt for for very local kind of
authority which actually is quite
interesting on the residential compound
then they're also quite vertical living
as you've mentioned you know you have
very high rise buildings here what
to a community because is it harder to
have a community when your neighbors are
not side by side but also up and down
well it's hard because when you think
about the rapidity of China's
urbanization yes it's as you've
mentioned it's been
40 years right it's been since 1970 78.
so at that point in time probably the
figures are disputed but maybe 11 15 18
were Urban now it's 68 open so in 40
years there's been Transformations 500
million people uh urbanized moving from
Village Life on the ground you know
tilling your crops and all the rest of
it
um two being put on a 25th floor of a
tower block people may remember that
happened in the 1960s in this country
that lots of kind of pensioners were
suddenly kind of thrown up in the air
and that that can can destabilize
communities destabilize you know your
sense of place and all the rest of it
in China there's a lot of ground living
so even those people who live in
high-rise buildings will come downstairs
and you'll find lots of people
um you know peeling shelling nuts or you
know whatever doing small scale business
to make an active Bob or two and trying
to create that certain sense of
humanitarian living
um but it's but I think the other thing
to say is that one thing which struck me
about China this may be going off track
but I felt that China rather than being
this kind of wonderful communal
lifestyle which I was imagining when I
went there 10 years ago
um it's actually it's almost like as if
Ayn Rand had created a country uh then
China would be it there's very much kind
of a self
um defense mechanism so Community Life
survives for as long Community is
important but really it's about the
family and your nearest and dearest and
that's where you that's where you
protect that's what you protect yeah
yeah I think I think that's definitely
you know right for a lot of people that
I know where rules are there to be
applied to other people but not when
you're fam his own interests are at
stake and one uh related part of that is
the whole phenomenon of chaitian the
whole phenomenon of demolitions that
happened
um because Austin I mean maybe you can
you'll be able to explain this much
better than I will but I remember
growing up in in 90s and naughties China
and that word chair demolish was just
everywhere why did that happen was it
just old buildings needed to be made got
rid of to make way for these big high
rises or is it that things that needed
to be built are fresh all together yeah
it's called urbanization you know as
somebody once said you have to break
some eggs you know so I think that
ultimately again I don't want to be too
blase about it because we often see
China as being fairly authoritarian and
wanting in its destruction but you look
back at post-port reconstruction in the
in the west or even if you go back 120
years in in America you see that a lot
of the same kind of things happen you
know people were forcibly remove areas
were demolished and new areas were were
created in China it's happened at a much
faster pace and much more in our
conscious lifetime uh so you know we can
we can reflect on it but effectively the
demolition of old buildings means that
you take down those pretty crappy
buildings and you're building now as we
say 25 story maybe even higher uh
high-rise concrete brand new buildings
that old statistic which was that
there's more concrete used in China
between 2010 and 2015 than in the entire
history of America right so is that true
I I think it possibly is there's
probably as much steel reinforcement
have gone into that concrete as well
right so there's an awful lot of you
know I mean it's a huge country huge
cities as you're talking about in a
second tier third tier City can be seven
million people uh first here can be 25
million people so these are you know
huge areas which have rapidly developed
uh in no time at all
um and I think that it's important to
recognize that the necessity to demolish
and create is kind of fundamentally
important yeah if you've ever seen the
film the Chinese mayor which is a
stupendous film it's one of the first
fly in the world documentaries by a guy
who generally forgot who was being
filmed
he was actually trying to create a new
Fresh modern city which would go on his
CV and he'd go further up the Communist
Party chain of command
um but to do that you know it was just
absolute demolition people moving people
out without uh you know without a
moment's notice demolishing their houses
and creating fresh land for development
but you know the reason I brought it up
um and the reason it was relating to our
um discussion about Iran is because I
actually think my enduring impression
from that was family members trying to
game the system trying to game the
compensation system because
um especially in rural areas which we'll
get on to
um I had relatives who were building on
their rubbish houses so that they can
claim oh my God my house is not just the
one single story thing where it has
three stories and therefore you have to
pay me this amount of compensation in
order to move me into a nicer City flat
that was always kind of an intriguing
part of things that they weren't
necessarily sad about their old houses
being
demolished if it meant that they could
actually you know profiteer a little bit
about of it it's interesting there's
very little nostalgia in China right I
mean it's creeping in now with the upper
classes and the more affluent middle
classes looking back on what maybe
they've lost which is understandable but
in general there's that idea that it's
about progress It's about development
it's about betterment it's about China's
future so people are willing to have
their their own house knocked down if it
maybe improves day a lot and that means
as you say whether it's gaming the
system or whether it's just the only way
they can make money they will be
prepared to sell their family home uh
but you can you can lose out on it
because some people who've built you
know very rickety second extension third
extension you know third stories on
their houses and then the government
will say well actually we've changed our
mind we're not going to develop this
Village anymore right so you're left
with having lost all of your savings
built this really you know crappy kind
of extension and you're left in penry
with no possibility of maybe selling it
on yeah so you know it you're still
under the whim of of government
development rules yeah and I want to
talk about that kind of Middle Ground
because it's something that you've
looked into a lot I've watched a um
shortlisted for an award uh film that
you made uh called uh Edge town
which is based on a town on the edge of
a city called which is where you teach
when you are in China
[Music]
[Music]
can you tell us about the story of why
was it interesting yeah well it's
interesting I mean we it came out of
because I teach architecture so it came
came out of some work we were doing some
students locally but effectively lots of
those migrant workers who are part and
parcel of more City developments I mean
some cities are 50 60 migrant workers
um but Sergio is slightly less but
there's large areas now where the
government is expanding and moving out
with the suburbs as the suburbs have
taken whole in China
um and so they needed they need to land
so there's a certain area chiffon area
which is quite large but one specific
area had you know a large group of
villagers living there in a pretty
rubbish conditioned houses they were
then told that they were going to be
knocked down and redeveloped they were
delighted they were going to make that
money what actually happened was one
third were knocked down and they got
houses they got their 21st story
buildings uh the second were knocked
down but then they would old that they
weren't going to develop therefore they
had their house knocked down and no no
compensation and the third you know one
third of that Village uh was wasn't
knocked down so they were left in their
own crappy conditions so we did the film
was about trying to understand how they
see the future in the past and of course
I mean maybe it'd be cliched but
obviously the people who had those new
houses thought the government was great
and the future was wonderful those
people who were living now in squalor
were looking back to the past uh for
some security from the state and thought
that what was actually happening was
this was a scandal so it's actually
quite divisive the whole demolition
progress thing
um because it just depends where you are
on the Chain yeah so it's a bit of a
gamble as to whether you succeed in this
and what particularly struck me it was
the fact that throughout these panning's
footage that you had which was really
gorgeous you had the urban soldier in
the background you had these high rises
you know in the distance on the horizon
and then these kind of half-broken
houses dirty rivers and all that sort of
stuff in the foreground so they were
within touching distance of urban life
but they weren't there because of gas
bureaucracy and delays and precisely but
a lot of those people still would be
working in the city right I mean so
that's the main thing but and Chevron
was made worse because you had
demolished two-thirds of it yeah yes it
was a real it was a real you know I went
back there maybe three years ago last
time I saw it and it's exactly the same
condition uh yeah it's a terrible
terrible story but it's replicated you
know hundreds of cities all over there
yeah so I was just going to ask you how
representative is that because we're
talking about how rapid China's
urbanization has been in um I myself
have seen Villages that you know I were
visited when I was younger turn into
Suburban suburbs of the of the city but
what happens with those places that
aren't turned into that why are they not
turning into that or is it just very
Myriad reasons and well you know some
places succeed and some places fail uh
it's just it's just life isn't it I mean
uh the the the strategy of the
government for the last 40 years let's
say has been to urbanize he has to
develop to make China into a modern
dynamic economy uh and it succeeded that
the rate of rate of urbanization which
is a signal factors of progress has been
reasonably successful now to do that
they've built lots of cities
not as many as we suspect but in because
they've actually taken old cities and
they've expanded them rather than if
you're building new in the middle of
nowhere yeah but but ultimately
um they not they haven't been brilliant
cities you know the the ambition has
been to build but not build quality so
again I hate to kind of reflect back on
the post-war generation but there was
those building those blocks that were
built after the war when we realized
that we're a bit Naf in the 1960s 70s we
knocked them down and built a bit more
quality that you know immediately that
necessity to build that kind of
engineering mindset no no architecture
was involved it was engineering project
to build a better uh China
um resulted in cities which were a
little bit Naf to say the least yes
um so what's happening in the last 10
years let's say architecture has started
to creep into the conversation and
actually having a quality Urban
environment rather than just the
urbanity for the sake of it uh and what
makes a good quality City well you know
things like Parks maybe things like a
decent places to walk nice streets
Pleasant to sit down but also cultural
venues and you know universities so you
have a mix of generations a bit of old
old world and a bit of New World
um so that hasn't really been the case I
mean China if you go to more cities in
China there aren't any parks you can
probably find a couple in Shanghai
um dating back 100 years but now like
Beijing new parks yeah I mean you know
just somewhere to sit and walk and
breathe cleaner air
um so in in Beijing they have a plan to
implement probably like 10 Central Park
New York Central Parks that that scale
or development within Beijing now again
that is going to require knocking some
buildings down but think back to how
Central Park was built right they
knocked lots of buildings down to build
Central Park so it's just you know
history repeating yourself but but
grander scale and a much more
authoritarian scale and possibly faster
and so you think that there is has been
a reconsidering of what makes a good
city in more recent years he said in the
last 10 years yeah I mean what makes a
good City for China was you know a was a
Target was a percentage you know we have
to hit 50 we have to hit 60 by 2020
about you know our goals of
you know moderately prosperous society
and all the rest of it so these are
these are all Targets you mentioned Eco
cities ecosities what do they mean even
right they just mean nicer cities than
what they were before because you
actually have some response to you have
some trees in them you know so I think
that these things are just almost
um bureaucratically
engineered definitions about what a good
City might be they're titboxed you can
literally go to cities in China and they
will have maybe 28 quality agendas key
performance indicators that you check
off to say what is a good City yeah you
sound quite disparaging about that you
do you not think that that is a tick box
exercise well you can if you want to but
you know I did it I did a research
exercise where I compared Tianjin
ecosity yeah uh which is a ready-made
ecosity whatever that might mean and I
compared it to London and on all the
tick boxes London performs better so you
could then say London is there for an
ecosity but that would be nonsense
wouldn't it because I don't think it is
um on any
is that something that the CCP itself
has been talking about is that like a
yeah because government Target as well
yeah because China is isn't a fool right
or Chinese government aren't fools they
recognize that if you want to be a
player on the world you have to you know
if you want to have investment you want
to make a city which is a playground for
kind of businessmen who maybe want to go
to the cinema and sit in the Park yeah
and have a coffee so Starbucks you know
was invited in so you know you have all
of this stuff so so China realizes that
if you want to sell yourself as a real
Global player because for 40 years and
Beyond China has been seen as a pariah
right a a congested polluted disgusting
place to be here with open sewers now if
you can just make that better and if you
can promote yourself as a sponge city a
city which kind of understands water
recycling or uh you know a Reclamation
city or a green city or a environmental
City you get a certificate which then
means that the person who's in charge of
the government policy at that level will
get a promotion but also your city will
get investment and you will be able to
kind of touch yourself on the world
stage so you know in some ways what
they're doing is making nicer cities and
I'm all in favor of that obviously yes
but I think that the bureaucratization
and the technical approach to it is a
little bit nap it's classic but it's but
it's seen in the west you know there are
people in the west perspective because I
think people in the west are becoming
more and more technocratic and
responsive to bureaucratic tick boxes
um and do you think because I think in
the west people have this image
especially of painting of being so
polluted you know air pollution is
probably the one of the first things
that people think of when they think of
Beijing
um is that getting any better in Beijing
and elsewhere in China is urban
pollution getting even better well again
depends who you read uh I mean uh lanjo
when I first went to China I went to
lanjo because it was in The Economist
magazine as the most polluted city in
the world and I went there and I thought
well I'm from South Wales you know as a
child and this is nothing on what I had
to go through and it was very pleasant
city
um but you know it depends on the
weather conditions and all the rest of
it what they've done in landure which is
really interesting well I if you don't
mind me saying so
um is that they've built glandular new
city which is you know 50 miles Outside
Lands or Old Town and to build landure
new city they have which is now an equal
City by the way they have taken the tops
off 400 mountains okay which you
wouldn't necessarily think is an
ecological kind of
policy but take the tops off the
mountains fill the valleys with the tops
of the mountains if you can imagine it
yes so yeah zero-sum gain you create a
plateau wow which then then build a city
on now that has created fantastic new
airflows which were
prior to that were disturbed by the
mountains so the air wasn't flowing
through the Land of Old Town so now
you've got a fantastic kind of breezes
which blow away the pollution of land
your Old Town
further down the chain somewhere
you don't talk about that cilantro is
now an ego City and your old is Nico
City so you know you think what I mean
what does it all mean you know so but
Lando itself is still a nice city but I
quite like the old industrial cities I
quite like a sense of that kind of
history and you know you meet some very
interesting people in those places
I think history is something that is so
hard to come by
um in China sometimes it's at once in
very ancient country
um objectively speaking but then when
you walk through a city like London you
feel so much more history when you walk
through it than when you walk through
objectively very ancient cities like
Nanjing or Beijing why is that is that
because of the rapid urbanization that
has happened
well there's that I mean you know every
every city has got a central business
district and actually in architectural
terms very few people know what a
central business district is when I was
living in China I was saying it all the
time because I thought it was a thing
and then when you go to America or UK
nobody knows what it is but so they they
create these kind of huge new Dynamic
business business areas
um but it's also the fact that you know
Britain has plaques and they tell you
all about the history and people go on
History walks uh in China there's a very
interesting difference in mentality
you've probably recognize it which is
that in the west you know we want
authenticity of our historical
sites to be crumbling
wrecks you know if you go to a castle
you want to see the castle as it was you
know 500 years ago in China you can go
to a thousand-year-old temple and you
look at this beautiful Timber tracery
and you think that can't possible that
can't possibly not have rotted right and
of course it was replaced last week and
they replaced it every every 10 years so
the the essence of the building is the
form the shape the material
which is authentic for China for us that
would be inauthentic that would be
Disney fired so it's a very interesting
kind of turnaround I don't know what you
think about this do you think that trend
is changing because I feel like for
people who are
um getting rich at first it's as you
said you know the people in chair farm
for example who are
um aspiring to a high-rise block
um but then there'll be also people in
the middle and upper classes now living
in these high-rise blocks who are
aspiring to a more authentic
down-to-earth life obviously they're not
aspiring to poverty and they're
definitely romanticizing certain parts
of rural living but there's now this
idea where you get to a certain level of
middle class and you think actually what
I really want is not this kind of
hyper-industrial hyper modern thing I
want a bit of History
well I don't know whether they well yeah
I mean I think they look back on these
things there's an example in um Beijing
which I always use so excuse me if I've
said this before but
um Beijing postcards is a shop which
sells you know old Imperial postcards
and when it opened up about 20 years ago
there were protests outside the shop of
people saying how dare you remind us of
our squalor and our past and our
Imperial Traditions right we're in a new
modern dynamic yeah within about seven
years he then his shop was full of
people buying those postcards because
people recognized within Beijing areas
with hudongs being demolished people
were losing a sense of family history
and they went back to be reminded so you
know it's a it's a natural progress
natural process it just happens a little
bit faster and a little bit more
uncertain but if you're you know if
you're fairly wealthy in China yeah you
may want to live on a you know a grand
um
Penthouse
penthouse on the top floor
um but normally you probably also want
to have a second house
and no one's going to be swapping their
Penthouse exactly so it's about it's
about clean air it's about play spaces
for your kids and that's where place
like uh in uh new town outside Beijing
that was one of President XI jinping's
um Big Ideas was to create this whole
new ecosity again outside of Beijing
where you could basically take people to
have a much better quality of life so so
you know the parks and the facilities
and the cultural centers are all there
already made for you and and do you
think we're seeing
um a turning point in the urbanization
process and we've talked about it
happening so rapidly
um one thing that comes to mind for me
is the fact that China's population
might be peaking very very soon if not
already and so they won't need as many
as much density of residential areas but
you've also yourself looked at rural
reconstruction in the countryside well I
mean all better off with corvid at the
moment economic recession so that you
know the the trends may be distorted by
what's actually now happening but yeah I
mean there's a there's there was a push
to uh put a maximum limit on Beijing and
shanghai's population so lots of people
were thrown out uh something to xiongen
to populate it but it was many many sent
back to their Villages and to do that
um you know you've had to create a
certain sense of uh place within the
villages so the villages were very often
those deserted places where people
migrate from and you were left here so
the young adult fit males went to work
in Shenzhen and left these villages with
like 60 year old grandparents and
five-year-old children so it was a
fairly I mean terrible situation
psychologically for lots of lots of
reasons and there are lots of problems
there so to encourage people to stay you
have to give them reasons so there's a
new rural revitalization program which
has been going on what's been going on
for quite 15 years but really in the
last five really it's kind of taken a
hole to encourage businesses to
encourage agriculture for
self-sufficiency reasons uh post covet
and post emergency but really they're
going to give a sense of that you it's
worth it's worth staying behind but it's
not worth moving yes and given that you
know Shenzhen especially kovid lots of
people in the last
last migration when they went to uh
Shenzhen around Guangzhou they found
that there weren't those jobs for them
and they were left on the streets they
they went straight back where they came
from and decided to make a job of it
back home so there's a lot of kind of
internal tensions and and Dynamics at
play but the but the rural
revitalization movement is then enhanced
by the fact that Architects are now
moving from building these kind of super
duper high-rise buildings in the urban
centers and are now being given
commissions to bills you know super
duper low rise uh but architecturally
impressive
um tofu factories and you know wine wine
distilleries and goodness knows what in
the in the village regions or paper
museums or whatever it might be yes so
it's all about in that kind of um
intangible cultural heritage it's all
about Local Economic Development and
Dynamics and it's also about
self-sufficiency of agricultural
production
um so no architect really gets a
commission privately outside the urban
area these are very much states you know
funded backhanders you know encouraging
architects now to go into the into the
rural areas sounds very Mouse you know
go back to the countryside uh and and
rebuild uh but you know there's it has a
it has a cachet well you know how how
effective are these top-down um decked
hats when it comes to this because as
you were talking I I remembered one
article that each previously written
about
um this award-winning Library which
looked amazing on the pictures but when
you went to visit it was actually just
essentially cement blocks and um it had
been refurbished to look like the
pictures but it had just then be
stripped because nobody was using it is
that right yeah there's lots of that
about yeah I mean look and that and that
won prizes but it wasn't actually
functional yeah well that's like Chinese
development isn't it you know so I was
always impressed by the fact that uh
whereas I remember John Prescott way
back when when he said we were going to
build four and a half million new houses
in 20 years China built four and a half
million new houses in 2016 in six months
right and you think amazing that's what
you want right but of course they've
never worked out where they should be
it's a percentage allocation so you tell
a city you will have you know 500 000
houses you never work out whether there
should be family houses or single person
houses the demographic shift is never
taking it into consideration and then
and they're also been now built by
developers who are going through the
biggest crisis uh in China's history uh
with a complete slump uh if 85 slump you
know so people are now refusing to pay
their mortgages so what you find is the
quality you build is as rubbish as ever
it was uh and that that's that's been
the case for the last 30 years that
first of all you don't necessarily have
the labor force to do impressive
buildings I'm always still impressed
when you look to go to Shanghai Beijing
you see high-rise buildings
where do they get those workers from
right they were trained in short order
six months ago they were farmers right
then they're given a piece of
reinforcing rod and told the climate are
you making me a bit nervous about
standing in these buildings so you
should be I'd give them another 10 years
before a couple of them started crumble
but
um I think that there's you know there's
shoddiness is going to build into the
system
um as well as into the way that maybe
well there's a phrase for it in Chinese
as well isn't that a dofaunting you know
tofu drags construction I think you know
it's about that was Consolidated as tofu
is yeah I mean look I'm over I'm
overregging because they've improved
over the last kind of 10 years not not
longer
um and you know construction standards
are are important and in some ways they
are moving to you know use different
materials so that concrete statistic I
gave earlier is now being downplayed
people are moving into Timber which
which actually was a material that was
frowned upon in China
um partly because you know the old um
Great Leap Forward when so much Timber
was just destroyed and burnt and chopped
down
um that now people want to protect it
also there's a tree planting every year
as you know uh to keep the
desertification back in China so trees
very you know don't have the same sense
of
um utility in China as they do in the
west you know we chop it down we use it
in China there's a bit more maybe Taoist
respect but generally there's a certain
sense that we've been through that when
we chopped it all down in all hell
Brokers but gradually gradually
gradually people are beginning to
realize that Tim Brushy is a useful
material yeah you know light and cheap
and easy to construct with and is there
has there been a return to um
traditional Aesthetics as well because
would I be right in stipulating that
China went through a period where
Western Aesthetics was seen as the top
uh tier of how a building should should
look has there been a return to that
because we're seeing other areas for
example in fashion or in food you know
there's this greater and some people
call this nationalism in a pejorative
way but it certainly there's a greater
confidence in your own traditional
culture has that been coming back in
Aesthetics of architecture as well
absolutely absolutely even in the most
modernist buildings my Anson who's a
architect who runs a company called mad
mad
um one of the very few Architects who've
actually worked abroad uh he's built
some very very tall skyscrapers in
central Beijing and he calls it
reflective of the of the Spanish way
kind of ink drawings I can't see it
myself but uh but you can see that
there's a harking back there's almost a
desperation by some people to situate
themselves in that kind of New
Nationalism and it's you know fair
enough it's um it's going away from
Pitch grooves and low scale um but there
is a sense that this is the new Dynamic
of how you recreate a new China do you
know what I mean so I do think that
there is something possibly
um dodgy about okay what do you think is
dodgy about well well I mean however we
want to situate ourselves in the
discussion on nationalism I think that
um that the idea of China opening up 78
all the way through to about 2011 when
before Xi Jinping came in that idea that
they were looking to the West they were
engaging with the west and and
subsequently maybe not since 2011 but
since about 2015 there's been much more
of a closing down and focusing back in
on China and that goes hand in hand with
the um self-sufficiency but generally
that idea about China has to defend
itself China has to identify with itself
trying to have to build a strong Nation
um which I think is possibly positive
because that's the way that China will
develop because it is one of the most
dynamic economies in the world but there
is a negative connotation to it and
building up those kind of cultural uh
Norms of looking back to history to
recreate you know images of the of the
future is not necessarily the most
Progressive one I don't think yeah
interesting I think it's always a
balance because I think sometimes in the
last 100 years has been the shame
associated with Chinese Aesthetics you
know we shouldn't be afraid of our
futons they are part of um our culture
and our history and that's something we
should be very proud of
um but obviously you know not this kind
of certain kind of exceptionalism
Chinese exceptionalism which is you know
exactly but if you look back in the
1920s which is really really interesting
in as much as after the you know after
the revolution
um and after the warring period and all
the rest of it in the 1910s 1920s you
have this thing which actually never
happened any other country which is that
you had Chinese architects who were told
or who were self-believing in the idea
that they're going to build a new China
right line but that new China was going
to be part of a global you know because
they just got rid of the of the Empire
so they were kind of part of the world
model and if you remember those kind of
uh protests in the 1920s for
westernization and democracy yeah so
there you have this kind of tension
where architects who are on one hand
building modernist
um
buildings I mean clear European
modernist buildings because they some of
them were trained in the west and their
their next commission would be a
traditional Chinese hat building uh with
tiles and all rest of it and The
Architects were hand in hand building
different Ubers as we say but they were
playing off the idea about what does it
mean for China to be a new modern
society is it joining the world or is it
you know going back and creating a a new
China new Chinese Heritage based on on
tradition
that conversation was a really Dynamic
one in the 1920s ended in or Hell break
English effectively but uh today that
discussion isn't really being had okay
you're not seeing that no and the same
way I don't see I don't see the
conversation being had out between why
are we rejecting the urban and the
urbanization which I'm a big fan of I'm
not a big fan of living in a village
coming from South Wales uh you know you
leave there to go somewhere good but
Architects are very very strongly kind
of rejecting the urban seeing it as
harmful environmentally damaging and all
rest and all that rhetoric from the
Western environmental Cannon is catching
on and people are now talking about
going back and building in bamboo and
mud and you know Twigs in The Villages
and that I think that's right
symbolically kind of quiet you've looked
at the new generation of Architects in
China you've written the book about
female Architects um in China many of
them presumably are going to have been
educated in the west has that Western
education not you know
made them have that dynamism that you're
talking about from the 1920s yeah but
you know it's like you know you can be
as Progressive and Democratic and
dynamic in the west and chatting down
the pub while you're over in London and
as soon as you go back to China and you
get your state commissions and you're
told what to do you don't rock the boat
and there's rules and regulations which
you can't kind of avoid so people people
Express themselves maybe in some
aesthetic uh way but the underlying
themes and the essence of what they're
building is very much related to what
the China China State I mean China State
requires so yeah it's um it's a shame
and I know there's a lot of people now
in China who are not going to the west
to be educated obviously the last two
and a half years they many of them
haven't been able to go to the west but
there's lots of kind of interesting new
developments I I want you know I I don't
understand it if I'm criticizing what's
going on in China because I'm a big fan
um of Chinese people not just dead but I
but I think that you know so there's an
interesting kind of play with history
and Dynamics but I think I can say the
essence is particularly wrong what I'd
like to see is more people coming to the
west and sharing those ideas cultural
exchange which works both ways
unfortunately
um and taking it back and actually kind
of really kind of transforming the way
that Urban landscape is is created in
China unfortunately lots of people
coming to the west and they're learning
all those terrible lessons of reduced
reused recycle so environment
censorship you know I mean the Chinese
state must be loving it all those
students going back saying I've just
come from the west and we're Banning
books and we're censoring you know
whatever
um it must warm their coggles well
that's a nice note to end almost
thank you so much for joining Chinese
Whispers thanks very much Sandy always a
pleasure
thanks for listening Chinese Whispers is
a podcast brought to you by The
Spectator and if you'd like to listen to
more just search Chinese Whispers
wherever you get your podcast from and
if you like what we do here you might be
interested in the Chinese Whispers
newsletter that I will be launching in
the near future sign up for free at
spectator.co.uk forward slash Whispers
And you'll be getting regular updates
from me on the most interesting
political and cultural news from China
as well as of course a smattering of
History that's spectator.co.uk forward
slash Whispers
[Music]